In Massachusetts, we
know a thing or two about
revolutionary ideas.
[GUNFIRE]
And at MIT, we know a thing
or two about innovation
and entrepreneurship.
Together, the
universities, communities,
and industries of Greater Boston
have transformed this region
into one of the
hottest innovation
ecosystems on the planet.
A place that's
home to everything
from the most dynamic and
forward-thinking companies
to the startups
nipping at their heels.
But we and other
innovators in the area
got to thinking: what
if we could go further?
What if we could cut
the time it takes
for world-changing ideas
is to go from lab bench
to marketplace?
Help entrepreneurs find support
to take on the most difficult
challenges?
Accelerate growth in the
toughest technologies
to tackle the toughest problems?
What could we build to
make this a reality?
We'd build an accelerator to
help ambitious startups get
from concept to company and
from prototype to production.
We'd provide financial support
for innovations that require
long lead times to develop.
And we'd establish a network
linking the ecosystems
of Cambridge, Boston, and
beyond to share vital equipment,
makerspace and diverse talent.
We'd rally our colleagues
across the region,
and together, make more
than financial commitments.
We would make a pledge to
use our energies, our brains,
and our skills to push the
boundaries of the possible.
We would build a new
kind of accelerator.
One as tough as the
technologies it will drive.
As revolutionary as the
ideas it will support.
To do all this, we
would build an Engine.
[MUSIC PLAYING]